Well,
um,
I had been to Afghanistan,
uh,
previously that was my first covering of
a war,
but I had written for rolling stone for
a few years.
And the short answer is I would always
write about youth subcultures,
like skateboarders,
criminals,
radical environmentalist.
And I pitched my editor the idea that,
hey,
I'll cover the military.
It's another youth sub culture.
Um,
but I think the other reason I wanted to
go to Iraq because I studied history in
school.
I was fascinated by it more actually.
And I had also previously worked at
Hustler magazine as a,
as an editor,
as an editor there.
And I,
I always felt that when I worked at
Hustler,
we are beneficiaries of the first
amendment.
And I thought,
now here's another way to,
um,
to,
to live the first amendment.
The military is giving me the
opportunity to cover the war from the
front.
And I feel it.
Um,
when I first covered troops,
it was in Afghanistan and I was a
little,
I spent a month with a heavy weapons
platoon in Kandahar.
And with those guys,
I was always sort of like,
should I let them know that I worked for
hustler cause I thought maybe they'll be
angry or some it'll offend some born
again Christian or something.
And it,
it got out and it really increased my
respect and acceptance in that platoon.
So by the time I got to Iraq or to,
to the Marine Corp prior to the invasion
of Iraq,
I kind of knew in a minute,
in a manipulative journalistic way that
hustler was a good card to play.
Um,
but it's more of a humorous thing.
Like they,
I knew that they would laugh about it.
Um,
what really I think made them accept me
as much as they did and not everyone
accepted me was just the fact that I
stayed with them and I believe in
journalism,
nothing beats,
um,
time and persistence.
Just follow people around and they kind
of,
it breaks down the barriers.
The fact that I followed them around
after we were getting shot at and ambush
of course also helps.
Okay.
In Afghanistan,
we had some rocket attacks and there are
big issues with land mines that were
blowing people up.
That was a different sort of tension the
first time.
In fact,
it was a worst,
just the fear of the fear of landmines
that we had in Afghanistan was worse
than actually being shot at.
And the first time I was really shot at
was at the bridge at Nasiriyah,
which will be depicted in episode of the
mini series.
And it was like,
strangely enough,
very exciting.
And it was strangely enough,
I,
and this was voiced by marines that were
by my side,
it was like,
wow,
this is just like a movie.
And it's weird to me that my reference
point and their reference point was
movies.
But that's the case.
It was,
I mean to see,
um,
you know,
and for some reason to have like a
mortar blow up sort of near you and you
feel the overpressure and you to see a
machine gun fire tearing into trees over
your head,
even though it's scary.
It's very exciting.
Well,
I think that,
um,
they were all dangerous.
I mean,
once you start getting shot at,
you know,
who knows?
But who knows what's going to happen.
But for me,
this happened time and time again.
We were in a convoy moving forward.
So at times a unit would have moved
ahead of us and they would say,
okay,
you're going to have enemy contact in
five minutes when you,
when you reached this turn in the road.
So then you're in the Humvee and you
know,
hey,
the last guys that drove up here,
they took rpg and machine gun fire.
It's going to happen to you next.
It was the anticipation that was always
the scariest.
Well,
when I came back from Iraq,
um,
a lot of my friends were like,
oh,
you know,
wow,
you were in combat.
It must be,
you saw something that no one else could
ever understand unless they've been
there.
And actually I disagreed with that.
The weirdest thing is there was an
element of being in combat that
confirmed to me what I'd read about it.
And I'd read studied history.
So I'd read a lot about it.
And it was weird as a writer and a
person who's sort of live the life of
the imagination,
I was like,
wow,
it's really cool that my imagination did
actually prepare me for what combat
would be like.
So there was an element of it that was
very familiar based on my intense
reading as a history student.
But the one thing that I really saw in
Iraq graphically and I'd never quite
understood was how attractive war is for
the combatants.
That basically in Iraq you had these
young Marines who had prepared for war
and it was pretty exciting for them to
finally get a chance to be in it.
And on the other side,
many of the people that were attacking
us,
we're professional Iraqi soldiers now,
many of them were actually working as
insurgents because the,
the Saddam's military had prepared for
an insurgency as we invaded,
but they were professional combatants.
So you had these young men on both sides
that were sort of fulfilling their
dreams.
They,
it was,
it was very self actualizing for the
Marines,
as I'm sure it was for the Iraqis.
And,
and it was a war is attractive to those
guys.
But in between is this massive civilians
who are being slaughtered,
who are suffering.
And I'd never quite realized a,
that,
uh,
for combatants war is kind of attractive
and be that truly what happens in war is
just civilians just get fucked.
You know,
there's no there,
there is no glory.
There's nothing for them except for
pain,
misery,
death,
suffering.
And you really see it in Iraq.
I really saw it.
Okay.